cette loi
[Musique]
tu es si mignonne tu as de jolies
oreilles
sourire est comme une pom pom croquerait
au soleil des longs
en temps de paix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le petit nez d'une petite fête
et la peau douce et filles
banny
c'est pour tout ça
branle en pensant à toi je suis sur ton
spectacle est une féerie chaque soir
j'essaie d'y venir
à la sortie et je n'aspire qu'à la
sortir je te trop
plus belle
j'ai été appelé de moins que j'ai
je ne suis jamais choqué quand tu dis
des choses
[Musique]
je ne suis jamais chanter les mots
des choses entre h
[Musique]
je sa patte
c'est pour
[Musique]
pour son toit je me branle en pensant à
toi puis je suis sur mon chat
noël j'aimerais tant
t'envoyer un gros cadeau un joli
cardigan
que tu es bien chaud mais je connais pas
ta taille alors je les fais
à une collègue au travail qui m'a
gentiment conseillé
elle est très élégante elle s'appelle
claire
la tournée
et même clementé chambre c'est fou ce
qu'elle peut te ressembler c'est pour
toutes ces raisons
je viens viens en pensant à toi
je vis avec l'air en pensant à toi puis
des fois je vis fonds chat
chaque soir j'essaie d'y venir moi et je
n'aspire qu'à sortir chante
[Musique]
non
ce que je voulais
choi
je ne
sans à toi
ce moratoire
je n'en pense pas
toi je me prends le conservatoire
mais le supplice
sharp
tu dis que c'est pas très bien que je
ferais mieux d'arrêter qu'à noël sous
son sapin
tu ne veux pas voir mon gros paquet
et que depuis l'automne mon chat est
tous collés comme un gros chewing
qui pas mâché
mais c'est toi qui n'as pas compris
qu'en fait c'est bien plus que ça
suivraient jusqu'au bout de la nuit
caché
c'est pour toutes celles
mon cas je me branle en pensant à toi
à voir à leurs proches
puis
je me suis sûr
je me suis
ciao
à me dire ce que je dois faire tu n'as
pas je suis quand même ton papa
désolé j'ai été un peu l'eau nous
rappeler les règles à appliquer à suivre
si on veut être drôle et pas choquer en
chansons laura l'eau on vous encourage
[Musique]
bon